tell us about your nighttime routine
what's it looking like at the moment
yeah so like I mentioned it you know I
take that nap and then after my nap I do
a lot of my reactive work like emails
social media you know people need to hop
on last-minute phone calls with me all
that [ __ ] that that's kind of like not
necessarily that doesn't fall into the
productive bucket but it's kind of more
reactive yeah like I save all of that
for later on the day you know because
I'd rather strike while the iron is hot
when I have low amounts of
decision-making fatigue or cognitive
fatigue early in the day and do a lot of
my productive work so I wake up from my
nap and typically you know there's
another hour and a half or two of just
you know kind of putting out fires so to
speak right taking care of all the [ __ ]
that would normally distract you earlier
in the day and then once I finish all
that I'll typically jump into a workout
you know and for me I just finished my
my Russian kettlebell rkc cert so for me
for the past few months it's been you
know snatches Turkish get-ups goblet
squats you know usually a lot of
concurrent strength endurance training
so I'm mixing that up with like you know
Aerodyne sprints rowing machine just
just you know a lot of kind of circuit
style work with the kettlebells and
typically it's something like that since
I just finished that syrup last week I'm
kind of getting back into this basic
weightlifting all right push pull hinge
etc so sorry the weight training or
high-intensity interval training in the
in the afternoon or the early evening
typically I'm working out from about
yeah kind of like that 5:30 to 6:30 yes
range right around in there I remember a
little while ago you mentioned that
you'd pivoted from performance to
longevity to look probably about a year
and a half ago I think what's where's
you goals at now definitely want
jeopardy you know because for years I
was competing in Ironman triathlon and
you know racing for Reebok and Spartan
training and and now I just want to feel
good you know I want to be strong
maintain muscle ice you know still if
anybody joins with me in a workout you
know they tell me a pure masochist but
you know even my workouts now or nowhere
near you know going out and crushing you
know two hours out in the mountains you
know and and you know or five hours on
the bike like you don't do any of that
[ __ ] anymore
I'm working out like forty to sixty
minutes max hey your condition it's done
based on your Instagram at the moment
your condition looks to be even leaner
than you were
looks to be the leanest I think I've
seen you um I'm about 185 pounds around
four or five percent body fat quite
leave and that's quite lean yeah but I'm
naturally lean like my dad's the same
way my dad doesn't believe in do much
training and he's proud you know he's 60
something he's probably like nine
percent body fat so wow that's genetics
good job I don't I don't really go out
of my way to like stay super lean but
you know my testosterone is fine my
thyroids fine you know so as long as my
endocrine system is working fine I'm
okay with just maintaining where my body
wants to be I don't you know because I I
def you know I'm a foodie I eat a lot of
food I punished a lot of ribeye steaks
and lard and ghee and liver and you know
I just my body doesn't hold on do a lot
of fat honestly just it's the way it
goes
so anyways though so on after after that
uh that kind of like early evening ish
workout that finishes up sometime around
6:30 or so typically after that I'll
make sure there's no more email fires to
put out no work that's left to be done
and then from about 7:00 7:30 on it's
all family time like we have these
wonderful like family dinners where we
play board games and go over our
gratitude journals and sing songs and
and and just just connect as a family we
all typically are gathering together and
making the meal together and everybody's
contributing and cooking and laughing
and playing music and so from like 7:30
until 9:00 it's just like full-on family
time dinnertime we finished dinner and
then we go play more music I'll read to
the kids or play them some songs in the
guitar you know we didn't we we don't
really go out to restaurants that much
but typically it's just like SuperDuper
focus
and relax and fun family time although
all the way up until after 9:00 and then
typically by about 9:30 or so you know
the kids are tucked away and then my
wind down routine in addition to those
red lights would be you know as we're
making that family dinner and you know
getting back into dinner I've typically
got you know the blue light blocking
glasses on again to start to you know
suppress any exposure to too you know
large amounts of blue light I what else
do I do
how long you a half full with the with
the blue light looking-glass is 90
minutes two hours before bed yeah it's
usually about ninety minutes two hours
before bed unless I plant like you know
whatever if my wife and I want to have
like you know like a you know a really
intensive sex session or something you
know we're plan being up till 10:30 or
11:00 you know talk and having sex stuff
like that like sometimes I'll just like
purposefully not do a lot to wine myself
but uh but yeah I also I tend to have a
pretty raging appetite even after dinner
so I'll typically do something with
glycine or gelatin in it which really
just so I make jello I make jello with
just like some some gelatin that'll mix
with coconut milk and little stevia
sometimes they'll put a prebiotic fiber
in there which also helps with sleep
like acacia fiber and then I'll just put
that in a food dehydrator for about a
day and you know stir that up keep that
in the fridge and I'll just give myself
a nice kind of like you know like like a
two inch by two inch piece of jello at
night sometimes we'll put a little bit
of almond butter on that a little touch
of sea salt and that's like that's my
go-to dessert for keeping my appetites
patience yeah yeah it's because I think
that gelatin the glycine just helps me
go to go to bed and not feel hungry
later on so I love that typically for
dessert after dinner and and then for
the wind-down routine other than that
what else do I do I'm my my go to
supplements for sleep or CBD
I do about typically high dose CBD most
the research on CBD that shows that it
enhances sleep uses a lot more than what
they use for like the ng oolitic effects
usually it's anywhere from 100 to 600
milligrams for sleep so typically I'll
take about a hundred milligrams of CBD
Sablan yep
yep I like to droppers I find out
respond best of that just hold it in
mouth for a couple of minutes and then
like I mentioned that a little bit of
glycine with gelatin and then also like
I mentioned magnesium so CBD magnesium
and a little bit of that gel oh that's
that's kind of like my go-to snack
what's you and what's your magnesium
supplement I'm using right now mag srt
by jigsaw health it's uh I think it's
glycerin 8 3 and 8 and citrate I think
you
what sausage I it's about 400 tell you
yeah so you just go to go to bowel
tolerance and man when you when you mix
that with having the vitamin C in the
baking soda in the morning it's great
for the bowels as well and then the red
light and then what I sleep on is I have
a gravity blanket you know a big I'm a
big fan of in addition to making sure
you sleep in a cold environment and
you're paying attention to light and
you're paying attention to not having a
lot of ambient noise in the bedroom
I think safety is big so I don't work in
bad an era I'm a laptop in bed I don't
even keep business books or health and
fitness books or anything like that up
in the bedroom it's all just like
fiction or something not related to work
and then I also find when I pull like
one of these big breathable 25-pound
gravity blankets over myself for sleep
it kind of amplifies that feeling of
safety even more so it just it's it's
super duper relaxing for me so I sleep
with a gravity blanket on top and one of
those chilly pad devices underneath
because the chilly pad will circulate
about 55 degree cold water under my body
while I'm sleeping
which really enhances your sleep cycles
quite a bit and then I've got an
essential oil diffuser and kinda like in
my office I'll diffuse uplifting scents
like you know peppermint rosemary etc in
the bedroom which is are like lavender
or Bergamo
or some really relaxing scent that I'll
defuse a
I'm asleep and then same thing I'll put
on sleep sleep blocking mask some foam
earplugs I have an app called sleep
stream on my phone and there's a lot of
research showing that uh you know
there's all these different noises that
can block out sound like white noise or
brown noise it turns out that pink noise
is the one that enhances your stick the
most so I put some pink noise on that
and then um let me think there's
anything else how are you doing that
well the plugs in well I got the foam
earplugs in but then the the the phones
and airplane mode next to the bed with
the sleep strap on just playing peak
noise just now if you photo speaker yeah
yeah cuz we have you know we have like
roosters and owls and all sorts of stuff
out here in the forest so I just like to
cover up that that ambient noise and
then I use breath work to just kind of
low myself to sleep typically four count
in seven count hold eight count out and
I'll do that for about five or ten
minutes and I'll just you know doze off
at that point just kind of breathing
myself to sleep
[Music]
you